hallo mein name ist nun komme ich bin
pokemon groß wichtig und deswegen mache
ich da heute ein video darüber unnormal
viele youtuber haben schon videos
darüber gemacht wie sie ihnen die
rumgelaufen rumgefahren sie mit dem
handy nach aber das ist nur noch 15
also das wollte ich jetzt nicht machen
naja gut also es regnet halt auch gerade
enorm viel draußen also deswegen werde
ich eigentlich nicht nach draußen gehen
da ich auf jeden fall schon alles
irgendwie runden pokémon bei you tube
gesehen habe bin ich letztes einfach so
ohne was wirklich also einfach nur so
ich bin ins netz gegangen bei cnet gibt
es ja immer diese discover stories auf
der rechten seite und der bahn einfach 7
pokémon gold story ich habe auch ein
screenshot vorn gemacht so wurden halt
einfach screenshots von usern gezeigt
die ihm die pokémon bei der hochzeit von
dem bruder gezockt haben oder weil der
freundin im krankenhaus oder so und da
habe ich mir gedacht ich suche mir
einfach mal die 20 coole screenshots
davon raus und zeigt ihr euch waren wir
erstmal ganz simpel an und zwar ist das
hier ein and on was ich bei einer person
im wartezimmer einfach mal dazu gesetzt
habe dem nächsten fotos die man doch die
rückseite seines autos frequenz jobs
geschrieben also von wegen okay leute
die hinter dem vater auf es kann sein
dass ich mal abrupt abbremsen weil ich
pokémon ko-spiele wird das ganze denn
hin dann habe ich mir gedacht okay dann
noch in welche cooleren bilder und dann
habe ich halt dieses bild hier entdeckt
wo ein us-soldat gerade im krieg war und
sie fangen wollte also ich kann ja
eigentlich nichts mehr zu sagen
bei diesem portal ihren der freund von
dem pokémon go spieler gerade seine frau
geheiratet und also seine freundin
geheiratet und dann wurde sie seine frau
ich doof trottel nasen kochen war nach
unten halt auch einfach pokemon und hat
bei uns auf der tanzfläche mit kids
kassensystemen war einfach ein genie auf
der tragfläche von einem flugzeug also
wenn's weiter nichts ist dem nächsten
foto was ich jetzt sage muss ich
wirklich sagen wer dachte ich mir nur so
wie wenn pokémon echt so groß wäre das
hier ist nämlich in einem
baseball-stadion und stellt euch mal vor
es gäbe wirklich so riesige krebse
apropos paypal habe ich übrigens auch
dieses modul hier von einem kazoo auf
einem wakeboard platz und auch noch
dieses foto hier von einem sturz auf
einem baseball platz also pokémons
lieben baseball bei mir es halt auch so
die sache dass immer wenn ich ihn die
polizei sehe oder wenn ich im auto sitze
und polizei hinter mir ist oder so dann
habe ich immer angst dass ich irgendwas
falsch machen ob bin ich an den vor
beiläufig was direkt hin die weglaufe
einfach nur lächeln und ein mann ja
diese person hat einfach pokémon
gespielt während da eine
polizeikontrolle war gut ich würde jetzt
sagen muss man die eier zu haben es ist
eine nichts verbotenes aber es ist schon
crazy ich sage euch alter irgendwann
brechen leute bei anderen leuten ein und
brechen die gesetze nur beiträgen welche
seltenen pokemon wirkt stellt euch mal
vor die ganze pokémon go sache sondern
verschwörungstheorie dass sie die ganzen
leute süchtig machen und irgendwann
machen gibt bestimmte seltene pokémon
beispielsweise auf dem berliner
brandenburger tor auf dem kölner dom da
müssen wir da oben klettern
das ist hier der anfang
schon aus roth hier hat sich einfach ein
rastplatz auf eine karte gesetzt
bei diesem punkt jemand in seinem
vogelkäfig doch einmal traut sie
entdeckt das ist natürlich auch cool ich
war letztens in köln und wollte dort wo
wie thorsten geht hab da übrigens auch
einfach so getroffen
wenn ich jedenfalls sind im restaurant
wenn du deinem burrito laden und sage
ich dem verkäufer hat ja ich hätte gerne
die zum dies und interagieren mit leben
und kommunizieren lava und rhede und
spreche oder ziele und alle anderen
irgendwelche sachen die ich damit die
macher diese person spielt einfach
pokémon go in einem bioladen und
entdeckt dort einen pokémon was ihnen
den mut macht wo soll das nur noch hilfe
wenn ihr das video hier gerade am
mittwoch soll dann kam auch gerade
pokémon go für ios raus ich habe mein
erstes pokémon war ein wunder dass ich
gefangen habe es mir einfach
heruntergeladen und das kommando dann
halt bei mir auch für spiele im
badezimmer allerdings bei dieser person
sie einfach auf der klobrille ist
natürlich auch ein cooler hall
was würdet ihr tun wenn ihr mit eurer
frau im krankenhaus werden weil eure
frau gerade die venen bekommt und ein
kind bekommt natürlich erstmal pokémon
beispiel und ein paar pokémon dort
fahren hier hat jemand bei der
beerdigung pokémon gaugisch wir sind ein
gp auf dem sarg der leiche entdeckt ist
jetzt ein bisschen makaber dann habe ich
noch zwei schilder entdeckt vorwärts
weiß dort werbung mit pokémon bau
gemacht haben und zwar einmal wenn ihr
pokémon trainer seit vom zu unserem
server sind die ganze zeit an und einmal
der sache von starbucks und zwar hat
dort einen schlangen pokemon einfach da
was geschrieben
ich weiß allerdings nicht weil wir diese
schlangen pokemon heiß ich weiß nur noch
dass es immer bei dem roccat im team
zusammen mit mercy und somit dabei war
aber ich weiß gerade echt nicht wieder
schreibt mir dass man die kommentare wie
normal diese schlange heißt das ging
aber ich glaube oder wackelt aber dieser
komische frosch ich bin wirklich ein
riesiger pokémon fällt auf alle staffeln
durch geguckt aber ich kann mich jetzt
mehr so krass dran erinnern com - die
letzte sache sicher zeigen wollte und
fragen mir die gestern freund gezeigt
schau dich um etat hat jemand pokémon wo
im stripclub gespielt und hat ein tauch
sie aufderhaar sparke einer stripperin
entdeckt an dieser stelle würde ich auch
dass die gebärden meine damen und herren
ich hoffe euch als gefallen es ist total
sven den daumen nach oben button werden
noch mehr pokémon so videos abend wollte
ich habe mir gedacht wenn jeder
youtube-video darüber macht wieder mit
dem handy liegen wir um pferd im pokémon
spank dann mache ich halt irgendwas
anderes und präsentierte einfach so die
skurrilsten orte an denen schon pokémons
entdeckt wurden doch das ganze hang
unterhalb von 5 euch anzuschauen
pokémon boss der zeitung bis dahin ist
werden schon gerüchte verstreut das ist
bisher das krasseste spiel des
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert sein soll
wir standen beispielsweise heute morgen
auf der straße nach maroni und doch
einmal kam das bei uns vorbeikommen
laufe handykunde sagte spiele puppen und
ihre lehrer vorging jeder mensch am
handy dies nicht in whatsapp sondern mit
pokémon go und ich mein ich bin ich mir
dagegen das ist so geil
von bringt die leute dazu raus zu gehen
man muss beispielsweise damit einer
schlüpfen irgendwie ein paar kilometer
laufen
man wird es eigentlich geht es halt dass
die leute nur noch auf die handy gucken
das spiel hat also sehr viele positive
seiten allerdings nur negative seiten
dass er echt leute gegen die an
total.com die orte fahren das schlimme
sachen passiert sind treibt mir doch mal
einfach jeder der jetzt da noch dran ist
eure meinung in die kommentare findet
ihr es gut oder scheiße da haben sie es
selber spielt auf zeit spielt es jetzt
gerade
guck dir das video spielt es vielleicht
nebenbei ich weiß nicht ich bin jetzt
auf weg ich warum gehe ich aus dem bild
ich muss doch jedem klar